في كهف تم حفره قبل الفي عام تعيش نوريا
الارمله مع اطفالها الثلاثه تقول نوريه ان
زوجها كان مدمنا مخدرات وقد توفي قبل اقل
من عام ودفعتها الظروف الاقتصاديه الصعبه
هي واسرتها للعيش في هذا الكهف ولا معيل
لها ولاطفالها
منذ ثلاث سنوات وانا اعيش مع اسرتي في هذا
الكهف العيش في الكهف صعب جدا لان
اقتصادنا ضعيف لا نستطيع شراء الحطب
والوقود فصل الشتاء من اصعب الفصول علينا
حيث تنزل الامطار والثلوج وتتساقط الاحجار
من فوق وفي الكهوف عقارب سامه
اسره طاهره ايضا تعيش في كهف اخر ولد
طاهره اربعه من الاطفال بينهم رضيع ذو شهر
واحد وهو مريض لا ينقطع عن البكاء تقول
طاهره ان اسرتها لجات الى العيش في هذا
الكهف قبل عامين جراء مشاكل اقتصاديه وعدم
قدرتهم على استئجار منزل
تشكيلات خير نواجه مشاكل كثيره فلا نملك
منزلا واقتصادنا هش وضعيف فالمنزل من
اساسيات العيش كما تعرف ومن سعاده المرء
امتلاك المنزل ووجود مصدر رزق ونحن لا
نملك لا منزلا ولا مصدر رزق
عدد هذه الكهوف الاثريه حوالي 14 الف كهف
وعلى الرغم من ادراج هذه المنطقه في قائمه
اليونسكو للتراث الانساني عام 2003 يئن
فيها اطفال رضع واخرون مراهقون لم يروا
واجهه المدرسه يوما في وقت تسعى سلطات في
باميان الى بناء مستوطنه لسكانها يطالب
سكان هذه الكهوف الحكومه الحاليه باتخاذ
خطه اكثر جديه لاخراجهم منها واسكانهم في
بيوت لائقه تحفظ لهم حياه كريمه وتحويل
هذه الكهوف الاثريه الى مكان يزوره
السائحون عبدالله نادر العربيه من مقاطعه
باميان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات